.
>> YES, THINGS CERTAINLY
ESCALATED QUICKLY.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOIN ME IS TIM BURCHETT OF
TENNESSEE.
YOU SEE HIM ON THE LEFT OF THE
SCREEN, THIS PHOTO YOU'RE
LOOKING AT, AS CONGRESSMAN
ROGERS LUNGED OVER.
WE SHOULD NOTE CNN HAS REACHED
OUT TO ROGERS' OFFICE FOR
COMMENT, INVITED HIM ON THE
PROGRAM.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
USED TO SEEING SCENES PLAY OUT
LIKE THIS IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE DON'T SEE IT HAPPEN ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR IN THE UNITED STATES
VERY OFTEN.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE WERE EXHAUSTED
LAST NIGHT, TEMPERS WERE
FLARING.
IT WAS LATE AT NIGHT.
TELL US WHAT YOU SAW.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE LEAD
UP TO THIS MOMENT?
>> WELL, YOU'RE CORRECT, IT WAS
VERY LATE.
REALIZE THAT BOTH SIDES HAVE
SOME OLDER MEMBERS, AND IT WAS
GETTING LATE.
I SUSPECT MOST OF THEM HAD
MISSED THE EARLY BIRD SPECIAL AT
THE SIZZLER.
SO THEY WERE GETTING
CANTANKEROUS.
AND MIKE, WHO'S A FRIEND OF
MINE, CAME BY AND SAID SOME
THINGS, PROBABLY IN HASTE, AS A
LOT OF US DO AND PROBABLY
RESPONDED TO HIM IN SOME THINGS,
AS WELL.
AND MATT HAD -- MATT GAETZ HAD
ASKED TO REVIEW SOME OF THOSE
RULES BEFORE WE VOTED ON
SPEAKER, AND HE FELT LIKE HE
WASN'T GIVEN ENOUGH TIME TO DO
JUST THAT.
AND ASKED FOR A LITTLE MORE
TIME.
AND YOU CAN SEE ME LATER IN ONE
OF THE TAPES GOING LIKE THAT
BECAUSE I'D ASKED -- I'D ASKING
OUR LEADERSHIP TO GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK SO WE
COULD PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER AND
GO OVER SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
IT WAS JUST AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE TIRED AND YOU -- AS YOU
SAID, IT WAS THE 15th BALLOT
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PASS.
>> BUT WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN YOU SAW
CONGRESSMAN ROGERS BEING
RESTRAINED?
JUST BEING THERE AT THIS MOMENT?
>> YEAH.
WELL, YOU CAN SEE ONE OF THE
EARLIER PICTURES WHERE I'D
ACTUALLY STIFF ARMED HIM, AND I
KNEW HE'D LOST HIS COOL.
IT'S THE SECOND TIME HE'D DONE
THAT THAT WEEK.
HE'D DONE IT EARLIER IN A
CONFERENCE MEETING AND MADE SOME
SIMILAR DEMANDS TOWARD SOME OF
US.
AND IT WAS UNFORTUNATE.
ONE OF THOSE REGRETTABLE THINGS.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
-- IT WILL BE REMEMBERED.
I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD TAKE
AWAY ANYTHING FROM LEADER --
THEN LEADER, NOW-SPEAKER
McCARTHY'S VICTORY BECAUSE IT
WAS HARD FOUGHT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK SOMETHING YOU
ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER IS THAT
LAUREN BOEBERT AND MATT GAETZ
HAD WORKED AROUND THE CLOCK WITH
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS TO GET SOME OF THESE
RULES IN PLACE, AND THERE WERE
SOME EXCELLENT RULES.
SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
YOU KNOW, YOU MENTIONED THE --
THE VACATE THE CHAIR WITH ONE
PERSON.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY IN PLACE SINCE
THE '20s, SPEAKER PELOSI HAD
TAKEN THAT OUT.
SO OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO IN
THE TENNESSEE -- DID IN THE
TENNESSEE LEGISLATURE, MY 16
YEARS, SOME TRANSPARENCY ITEMS.
YOU'RE PUTTING MORE FISCALLY
CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS ON THINGS
LIKE THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AND IF YOU REMEMBER, THE
TRANSPORTATION BILL WAS A HUGE,
HUGE BILL, OVER $1 TRILLION, AND
IT WAS PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
AFTER A 16-HOUR MARKUP OF THE
BILL.
AND THEN IT WENT TO THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE, AND SHE WITH
SOME HELP OF SOME LOBBYISTS AND
SOME ADVISERS ACTUALLY REWROTE
THE ENTIRE BILL.
AND THEN IT WAS PUT ON THE FLOOR
WITHOUT ANY DEBATE.
AND WE WEREN'T ALLOWED TO AMEND
IT AT ANY STEP FURTHER.
SO THESE THINGS THAT WERE PUT
INTO PLACE THAT MATT GAETZ
FOUGHT VERY HARD AND LAUREN
BOEBERT AND SOME OF US FOUGHT
HARD TO PUT INTO PLACE WERE
THINGS THAT WILL PREVENT THINGS
LIKE THAT FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS --
>> THAT WAS WHAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK.
I WAS WONDERING WHETHER OR NOT
BECAUSE GAETZ WAS ONE OF THE
LAST HOLDOUTS, WHETHER YOU HAD
FELT IN IN WAY HE HAD BEEN
JANUARY TAGNIZING COLLEAGUES TO
THE -- JANUARY TAGNIZING
COLLEAGUES TO THE POINT WHERE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WAS ABOUT TO
HAPPEN.
SOUND LIKE YOU DON'T PUT THIS ON
GAETZ.
>> I DON'T.
I DON'T.
HE'S A MEMBER.
HE HAS A RIGHT.
HE REPRESENTS THE CONSTITUENCY.
IF YOU EVER GO DOWN TO THE VERY
NICE AREA OF FLORIDA WHERE HE --
MY WIFE AND I OCCASIONALLY GET
TO GO DOWN THERE ABOUT ONCE
EVERY TWO YEARS, DOWN TO THE
DESTIN AREA.
HE IS VERY POPULAR DOWN THERE.
THE REASON HE IS IS BECAUSE HE'S
AN INDEPENDENT THINKER.
HE'S AN ATTORNEY.
AND HE STAND UP FOR HIS PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS DOING.
THAT'S WHAT ALL 435 OF US SHOULD
DO.
AND ALSO HE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
LAUREN BOEBERT THAT THEY -- HE
WOULD NOT FOLD UNTIL THE RULES
PACKAGE -- IN FACT, HE WAS ABLE
TO READ IT.
AND THAT'S -- LIKE I SAID, WHERE
YOU SEE THAT, TOOK ABOUT TAKING
A ONE-HOUR BREAK, ADJOURN FOR
ONE HOUR.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
WORK OUT.
WE WERE GOING TO ADJOURN AND
COME BACK ON MONDAY.
AND MATT -- AND MATT -- YOU CAN
SEE WHERE HE AND I ARE TALKING,
AND LAUREN AND HE ARE TALKING.
AND HE DECIDED IN FACT THAT --
AND LEADER McCARTHY HAD COME UP
AND LITERALLY PROMISED HIM THAT
WE WERE -- WE'D WORK THROUGH ALL
OF THAT.
AND MATT TOOK LEADER McCARTHY AT
HIS WORD.
THEY'D HAD SOME WORDS DURING THE
WEEK, AND MATT HAD SAID SOME
THINGS ON THE FLOOR ABOUT THE
LEADER.
AND I THINK SPEAKER --
NOW-SPEAKER McCARTHY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE THOSE THINGS RIGHT.
I THINK HE WILL.
AND I THINK -- GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY.
>> I WAS GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ HAS SAID IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE OF SOME
OF THESE CONCESSIONS THAT
SPEAKER McCARTHY HAD TO MAKE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE
RUNNING THE HOUSE IN A
STRAIGHTJACKET.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO GOVERN, IMPOSSIBLE
TO PRESIDE OVER THE HOUSE FOR
THE UPCOMING SPEAKER, THE
INCOMING SPEAKER, BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THESE CONCESSIONS?
I MEAN, ALL IT TAKES IS ONE
MEMBER TO GO TO THE HOUSE FLOOR
--
>> SURE --
>> RIGHT.
COULDN'T MATT GAETZ DO THIS NEXT
WEEK?
START IT ALL OVER AGAIN?
>> HE -- HE COULD DO IT EVERY
DAY, BUT IT'S JUST A VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE IS WHAT IT IS.
AND IT WOULD BE A SIMPLE
MAJORITY.
SO I THINKING ABOUT IN
LEADERSHIP AND BEING ABLE TO
CONTROL THE FLOOR VOTE IS A KEY
THING, AND OF COURSE THE WHIP,
OUR NEW WHIP WHO WAS STEVE
SCALISE, NOW IT'S TOM EMERT,
WILL DO AN EXCELLENT JOB.
GUY RESENTHALER IS NUMBER TWO,
WE CAME TOGETHER AND THEY HAVE
AN EXCELLENT MACHINE, THEY KNOW
HOW TO WORK THE FLOOR AND DO IT
WELL.
I THINK IT LITERALLY -- I DO
THINK IT HOLDS THE SPEAKER
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE, TO
THE REAL PEOPLE.
IT IS CALLED THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE
FOR A REASON.
AND THAT THING WAS IN PLACE
SINCE THE '20s.
AND WE NEVER HAD A PROBLEM WITH
IT UP UNTIL THEN, AND THERE HAVE
BEEN VERY TIGHT -- TIGHT
MAJORITIES AND MINORITIES, FIRST
THE REPUBLICANS, THEN DEMOCRATS.
JIM, I THINK IT PUTS THE PEOPLE
MORE IN CHARGE OF THEIR HOUSE,
WHICH IT SHOULD.
YOU DON'T HAVE A BULLY -- GO
AHEAD.
>> YEAH.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS -- WHEN IT
WAS ALL OVER, THE SPEAKER, KEVIN
McCARTHY, THANKED FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP FOR
PLAYATION ROLE IN THIS.
-- PLAYING A ROLE IN THIS.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I DO WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SHOULD
DOUBT HIS INFLUENCE.
HE WAS WITH ME FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SOMEBODY WROTE THE DOUBT OF
WHETHER HE WAS THERE, AND HE WAS
ALL IN.
HE WOULD CALL ME, AND HE WOULD
CALL OTHERS.
AND HE REALLY WAS -- I WAS
TALKING TO HIM TONIGHT --
HELPING GET THOSE FINAL VOTES.
WHAT HE'S REALLY SAYING REALLY
FOR THE PARTY AND THE COUNTRY,
THAT WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER.
>> SETTING ASIDE THAT LAST PART
OF WHAT SPEAKER McCARTHY SAID
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE COUNTRY COME
TOGETHER, I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS WOULD SHARPLY DISAGREE
THAT.
VERY LIKELY AND DEFINITELY
SHARPLY DISAGREE WITH THAT.
BUT DO YOU AGREE THAT IT WAS A
GOOD IDEA TO HAVE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT PLAY A ROLE IN ALL
THIS?
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR TRUMP,
HONESTLY.
I KNOW THAT GAETZ AND BOEBERT
DID NOT RECEIVE A CALL FROM HIM,
AT LEAST WHEN I WAS SITTING
THERE WITH THEM.
SO MAYBE SOME OTHER MEMBERS DID,
AND IF THAT INFLUENCED THEM IN A
POSITIVE WAY, I THINK THAT'S A
-- THAT'S -- THAT WOULD BE A
GREAT THING.
JUST EVERYBODY'S -- EVERYBODY IS
ADDING TO THE POSITIVE CATEGORY,
AND YOU KNOW, VICTORY HAS 100
FATHERS, AND DEFEATS THE NORTH.
AND SO I PILE ON FOR ALL I CARE.
I DON'T CARE WHO CALLED -- I WAS
JUST GLAD TO SEE KEVIN
McCARTHY -- I VOTED FOR HIM 15
TIMES.
SO THERE WAS NO QUESTION MY
LOYALTY OF ANY OF THAT.
AND SO -- BUT I WAS -- I ALSO
MET WITH HIM EARLY ON, AND I
MADE VERY SIMILAR REQUESTS THAT
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS DID.
AND I RECEIVED ABOUT 85% OF WHAT
I'D ASKED FOR TO MAKE IT --
>> YOU'RE NOT WORRIED,
CONGRESSMAN, THAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE YOUR PARTY IS NOT READY FOR
PRIMETIME.
>> NO, HECK NO, BROTHER.
HONESTLY, JIM, AND WE MISS YOU
IN KNOXVILLE, BROTHER.
BUT THE TRUTH IS IS THAT --
>> I MISS EVERYBODY KNOWN THERE
IN KNOXVILLE, TOO.
>> YES, SIR.
WE -- I HAD MORE DEBATE THIS
WEEK IN CONGRESS, MORE
MEANINGFUL DEBATE, MORE
INTERMINGLING, I WOULD GO OVER
AND TALK ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE, I
TALKED TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
SQUAD, AOC AND OMAR AND ALL OF
THEM, AND SPEAKER PELOSI SAT
BESIDE ME, CHECKED ON MY
DAUGHTER WHO GOT HURT IN A
LITTLE -- A HORSE ACCIDENT,
BECAUSE SHE HAS A GRANDDAUGHTER,
HER NAME IS ISABELLA, AND MY
DAUGHTER'S NAME IS ISABELLE.
AND SHE ASKED ME ABOUT MY WIFE,
KELLY.
IT GAVE US TIME TO INTERACT.
WE INTERACTED MORE THIS WEEK
THAN WE HAVE IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
AND IF ANYTHING, I THINK THAT
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING IS WHERE
IT WAS AT.
WHEN I USED TO BE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WE HAD VERY -- I
CAN'T REMEMBER, THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I WAS IN MY 16 YEARS WE
WERE IN THE MAJORITY.
IT DIDN'T CHANGE MUCH BECAUSE WE
WORKED TOGETHER ACROSS THE
AISLE.
STEVE COHEN OUT OF MEMPHIS, HE
AND I WORKED WHEN I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE, WE RAISED THE SPEED
LIMIT TOGETHER, YOU KNOW.
HE CALLED MY MAMA WHEN MY DADDY
DIED.
WE HAVE THOSE KIND OF
RELATIONSHIPS.
I THINK THIS WEEK A LOT OF
THAT -- A LOT OF THOSE BARRIERS
DISSOLVED.
AT LEAST A LITTLE BIT.
AND SO YOU KNOW, IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE -- DEMOCRACY'S NOT A
PRETTY THING SOMETIMES.
IT'S UGLY -- SOMETIMES IT'